un bon soir lundi 1er mars le début
d'une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans le
journal de la rédaction voici les titres
en ce jour de rentrée les jeunes de
chambourcy n'ont pas repris le chemin de
la classe les établissements scolaires
de la commune sont fermés pour au moins
une semaine après la découverte de
treize cas du variant sud africain du
commis de 19 depuis le 12 février
ce week-end une grande campagne de
dépistage a été organisée sur place
auprès des habitants d'avoir la
possibilité de jardiner dans l'espace
public c'est le principe des permis de
végétaliser de plus en plus de villes
dans le département s'y met c'est le cas
à saint quentin en yvelines ou cinq
communes l'ont adopté quels sont les
objectifs et comment fait-on pour
obtenir son permis de végétaliser
éléments de réponse et puis le soleil
était au rendez-vous ce week-end dans
les yvelines l'occasion pour les
sportifs de se dé confiné de profiter de
conditions agréables à plaisir les
courts de tennis extérieurs ont été
prises et reportages à la fin de cette
édition et pour ce week end ensoleillé
jardiner était aussi un bon prétexte
nous irons à guyancourt également tout à
l'heure
des cas du variant sud-africain ducobu
19 détectés parmi à des élèves et
personnels d'éducation à chambourcy
c'était avant les vacances scolaires
suite à cette révélation qui a entraîné
la fermeture des écoles pour au moins
une semaine l'agencé régionale de santé
à dépister massivement les habitants de
la ville pour ce faire le gymnase
georges gallienne s'est transformé en un
centre de dépistage pendant tout le
week-end plus de 1000 personnes ont été
testées
le reportage de mélanie poquet de
mickaël millero des écoles fermés au
moins jusqu'au lundi 8 mars 1200 élèves
de chambourcy sont concernés par la
mesure 13 cas positifs aux variants sud
africains ont été détectés depuis le 12
février dernier des adultes comme des
enfants de l'école maternelle au collège
si on prend par exemple l'exemple du
collège andré derain qui est qu un
collège à vocation intercommunale
puisque la moitié l'effectif et quand
bruce yam et l'autre moitié hors jeu
relais de surcroît l'ensemble des
enfants de chambourcy vont au lycée vont
dans les lycées de saint germain en laye
et on peut imaginer assez volontiers
qu'il puisse y avoir des contaminations
dans les deux sens contagiosité plus
rapide et plus forte
effet peut-être encore méconnu un
week-end de dépistage a été organisée
sur la commune
avec cette action la rs espère pouvoir
isoler plus vite les élèves et le
personnel éducatif
l'objectif c'est d'aller vite et de
venir voir vite ce qui se passe sur
cette commune et puis le bassin de
population pour qu'on puisse prendre des
mesures supplémentaires si c'est pas
suffisant et si on a un virus qui tourne
encore plus que ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer plus de 1100 personnes ont été
dépistées durant deux jours bien que je
n'aie aucun symptôme je pense qu'il faut
quand même c'est 6
il ya eu des cas dans l'école de notre
fils donc du coup on était pour se
rassurer aussi et puis étant
professionnels de santé aussi retournant
au travail voilà pour éviter de
contaminer tout le monde est la
municipalité a également commandé 600
tests salivaires pour les élèves de
moins de 11 ans et en cette semaine de
rentrée scolaire des tests salivaires
pcr vont être déployés dans les écoles
primaires l' agence régionale de santé
et débute la campagne de dépistage ce
lundi dans les trois académies
d'ile-de-france l'objectif atteindre 40
mille tests salivaires par semaine dans
la région en mars 60 milles d'ici la fin
de l'année scolaire est les tests seront
analysés à sous 24 heures et les
variants rechercher dans les
échantillons est dans les yvelines les
tests devraient démarrer dès jeudi
la région ile de france où les variances
sont désormais majoritaires dans les
nouvelles contaminations des chiffres
qui augmente c'est le cas notamment dans
les yvelines
en une semaine le taux d'incidence a
largement grimper dans le département
plus 40 entre le 21 et le 28 février le
taux d'incidence c'est le nombre de
nouvelles personnes contaminées pour
100000 habitants le taux de tests
positifs est également à la hausse du
côté des hôpitaux l'attention ce temps
sur les places de réanimation au niveau
francilien et dans les yvelines on
comptait hier à 571 patients
hospitalisés soit 8 de plus que la
semaine dernière
42 en réanimation depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1373 personnes sont
décédées du colis de 19 dans les
établissements de santé du département
par ailleurs on apprend qu'une centaine
de personnes a été verbalisée dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche à la boissière
l'école alertés par un cortège de
voitures suspect au péage de
saint-arnoult les gendarmes des yvelines
ont découvert qu'une soirée avec l'en
destine se tenait dans une grande
propriété privée de la commune
le tout en ignorant bien sûr les mesures
sanitaires en vigueur les organisateurs
de l'événement été identifiés ils seront
entendus dans les prochains jours par
les forces de l'ordre
dans le reste de l'actualité la
mobilisation des gilet jaune ce samedi
vers ça versailles c'était averse à une
centaine de personnes s'étaient donné
rendez vous sur la place d'armes pour le
départ de la manifestation dans la ville
autorisée par la préfecture des yvelines
les principales revendications sont les
mêmes que celles affichées au début du
mouvement fin 2018 mise en place d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne hausse
du pouvoir d'achat et baisse des prix à
la pompe mais de nouvelles colère ont
émergé avec la crise sanitaire et les
mesures restrictives décidées par le
gouvernement et sur la loi également est
dite de sécurité globale qui doit être
examiné par le sénat après adoption à
l'assemblée nationale écoutez ses propos
recueillis par justine braz et la colère
vous savez ce que fait le gouvernement
en ce moment elle détruit notre pays
elle fait mourir notre pays une france
si belle si jeune mais malheureusement
ce gouvernement
et nous détruit et des gilets jaunes
étaient également présents le lendemain
au péage de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines à
l'occasion du retour des vacances
scolaires ils ont mené une opération
péage gratuit pendant une trentaine de
minutes à saint quentin en yvelines les
permis de végétaliser fleuriste
plusieurs communes de l'agglomération
dont mise en place avant d'accueillir
nos invités à ce sujet et eléonore
sinoquet de la rédaction tv 78 tête avec
moi bonsoir qu'est ce qu'un permis de
végétaliser alors c'est tout simple
c'est la permission de la mairie de
votre commune de jardiner sur l'espace
public
concrètement cela veut dire que vous
pouvez végétalisée gratuitement un petit
bout de trottoir le tour d'un an ou même
votre pas de porte en soi un lieu que
vous appréciez en france et en 2015 que
les premiers permis de végétaliser sont
apparus à paris dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
cinq communes l'ont mise en place
montigny le bretonneux villepreux
maurepas plaisir et la dernière en date
c'est les clayes-sous-bois qu'il a voté
en conseil municipal le 8 février
dernier
quel est l'objectif de ces permis alors
il est double d'abord c'est simple c'est
rendre la ville plus belle c'est plus
joli d'avoir du végétal que du béton
l'autre enjeu c'est l'aspect écologique
évidemment lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique améliorer la
qualité de l'air favoriser la
biodiversité en réintégrant du végétal
dans les villes les permis de
végétaliser permettent tout cela mais
comment fait-on pour obtenir son permis
de végétaliser alors il faut en faire la
demande sur le site internet ou
directement auprès de la mairie de votre
ville il y a généralement une charte
d'engagement et des règles à respecter
pour pouvoir végétalisée ensuite le
dossier sera étudié par la municipalité
la ville va vérifier notamment si le
projet de végétalisation est faisable ou
est ce que vous voulez végétalisée et si
le projet respecte bien toutes les
règles et si tout est bon la mairie vous
enverra votre permis en un mois environ
après il restera plus qu'à jardiner
merci et l'honneur pour toutes ces
précisions continue ajustements a parlé
de ce sujet avec mes invités véronic
mort un bon soir par visioconférence
pour ça maire-adjoint de la commune de
plaisir délégué à l'embellissement de la
ville et la promotion de la nature la
ville
quelques mois a lancé son permis de
végétaliser on va en parler dans un
instant également avec nous bertrand
houillon bonsoir d'achat au maire de la
commune de magny les hameaux on va avec
vous élargir aussi ce sujet et parler
d'un projet que vous menez actuellement
dans la commune celui de déminéralisée
les cours d'école déjà peut-être
bertrand ayant une petite réaction à
cette mise en place progressive à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des permis de
végétaliser on l'a vu dans la chronique
5 commune yvelinoise s'y sont déjà pliés
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
initiative d'aller vers ces permis de
végétalisation
c'est une très belle initiative pour
pouvoir réinvestir l'espace public au
niveau des habitants et puisque depuis
trop longtemps maintenant on a donné
l'impression à l'ensemble des citoyennes
citoyens qu'ils n'avaient pas accès
finalement aux blues qui l'ont couvert
absolument rien faire mais il faut
laisser l'initiative puisque à l'espace
public appartient à tout le monde au
niveau de magny les hameaux on a déjà
mis en place ce type d'expérience a
forcément avec un permis en fait on a
tout simplement défini des espaces sur
nos espaces verts publics et on a
proposé aux gens qui le souhaitaient d'y
aller tout simplement et ça fonctionne
petit à petit voire même à d'autres
endroits où on n'avait pas imaginé bas
des habitants nous ont tout simplement
proposé de prendre en charge l'ensemble
du fleurissement de la verità lisation
de ces espaces ils le font avec notre
accord tout simplement
mais je n'ai pas précisé vous êtes
également vice président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines véronique morin pourquoi
plaisir à voir mis en place justement
ces permis de végétaliser et bien nous
avons mis en place c'est perdu de
végétaliser parce que ça s'inscrit tout
à fait dans notre démarche
aujourd'hui pouvait lever encore plus
nature jusqu'à présent nous avons tout
50% notre espace qui vit ji talent avec
les forêts ou les espaces verts mais
notre ambition est d'aller plus loin
encore et c'est une façon de
sensibiliser d'autant plus les
citoyennes et citoyens à
l'embellissement de leur ville et à la
biodiversité c'est la trame de fond
aussi de cette démarche c'est de
favoriser la biodiversité et au travers
d'un père me planter en
citoyen 5 1 par vraiment le territoire
et cette démarche puisque vous parlez
d'embellissement il ya aussi des
avantages écologiques à végétaliser à
revégétaliser sa commune c'est ça il ya
un grand nombre d' avantage certain
embellissement mais bien évidemment ça
donne des points de fraîcheur c'est une
façon aussi de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
ça permet de créer du lien entre les
citoyens parce que parfois c'est avec
plusieurs plusieurs voisins que les
choses se mettent en place
donc il n'y a que du bénéfice à avoir
cette cette démarche est ce que beaucoup
de plaisir aujourd'hui fait la demande
d'avoir ce permis de végétaliser alors à
ce jour nous avons mis en place le
permis végétalisée à luton à ce jour un
certain nombre de demandes ont été
faites trois déjà ou ont abouti et les
panneaux que les plaisirs wa pourront
arborer sur leurs petits terrains ont
été remis en début du mois de février
donc la végétation est en train de se
réveiller et le mois de mars étant
propice aux plantations nous allons voir
fleurir ces petits panneaux et je
précise d'ailleurs que la ville
organisera une opération fleurissaient
votre rue avec les habitants qui
pourront se voir pouvoir bénéficier de
graines gratuite en toutes les
informations vous avez vu le site de la
mairie de la ville de plaisir s'afficher
en bas de l'écran bertrand au lion qui
est avec nous je le rappelle avec nous
aussi également maire de la commune de
magny les hameaux alors toujours dans
cette thématique de la végétalisation
vous amener un autre projet dans votre
commune celui de déminéralisée est les
cours d'école c'était l'un de vos
engagements lors de la dernière campagne
des élections municipales déjà pourquoi
ce projet ce pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord des pouvoirs des imperméabiliser
les sols pouvoir créer des îlots de
de fraîcheur pour pouvoir lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique et notamment
dans des cours d'école qui sont très
souvent traditionnellement et grands est
drones et avec peu tard
et puis aussi pour pouvoir permettre
d'avoir un support ludique et
pédagogique pour l'enseignement de
l'environnement et de la nature
et puis un dernier point important aussi
de pouvoir des genres et les cours
d'école en peut-être mettant moins de
jeux de ballons qui sont très souvent
accaparés plus par les garçons pour
pouvoir donc avoir plus d'espacé aussi
pour les filles et un vrai partage de
l'espace pour l'ensemble des enfants
dans toute une cour d'école pour ce
projet vous souhaitez d'ailleurs vous
inspiré d'un exemple qui se fait à paris
c'est les cours oasis qu'est ce qui a
été fait justement là bas et qu'est-ce
que vous de quoi pourriez vous vous
inspirez justement alors en effet on a
regardé en fait partout où il y avait eu
déjà ce type d'actions menées le
principe est de d'enlever du sol dur
donc de casser du goudron en quelque
sorte pour pouvoir ensuite créé plus de
finement le reste de pouvoir le mettre
en enherbées ou bien en copeaux en
copeaux de bois ou en végétalisation
l'ensemble de l'espace doit vraiment
être repensée avec tous les usagers de
cet espace de cour d'école pour qu'il
soit particulièrement adapté au jeu des
enfants mais aussi à leur éducation et
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle on
veut justement intervenir avec les
enseignantes et les enseignants auprès
des enfants avec les parents d'élèves
pour pouvoir justement mettre en place
l'ensemble de cette démarche
ses liens et à une concertation qui va
être mené auprès des enseignants des
parents d'élèves et des élèves aussi
c'est exactement ça on vient de répondre
à un appel à manifestation d'intérêt du
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse qui nous attend
agne dans cette démarche pour pouvoir
justement travaillé sur une co
élaboration avec les rangs avec les
enseignants avec les parents d'élèves
pour pouvoir mener à bien ses projets
c'est vraiment important parce que c'est
leur espace de vie c'est des espaces
encore une fois particulièrement
éducatif qui doivent être utilisées à
plein par l'ensemble de l'équipe
enseignante et puis les enfants
un dernier mot je reviens avec vous
véronique morin justement de réaction
comme j'ai fait réagir bertrand audience
sur ces permis de végétaliser le fait de
déminéralisée les cours d'école leur
apporter justement plus de
végétalisation est ce que plaisir
pourraient travailler sur le sujet
travail peut-être déjà sur le sujet que
j'allais aller vous dire c'est
effectivement essentiel et c'est quelque
chose sur lequel nous avons déjà mené
des actions en l'occurrence nous avons
démarré un programme de renaturation des
cours d'école donc aujourd'hui nous
avons trois écoles dans lesquelles des
armes ont été réimplantés avec des bancs
les zones enherbées qui permettent aux
enfants de de pouvoir être en contact
avec cette nature et nous avons pour
projet sur les années qui viennent de
continuer ce déploiement sur toutes nos
cours d'école
c'est effectivement essentiel je rejoins
messieurs millions sur les courts oasis
c'est un ça peut être un projet de long
terme donc là nous pour l'instant nous
sommes sur ces étapes de de
réimplantation d'arbres à ce titre nous
avons deux projets qui sont dans le
budget participatif de l'île de france
actuellement soumis au vote des citoyens
de guides de france pour pouvoir
amplifier cette renaturation des cours
d'école et plusieurs communes de saint
quentin d'un garçon dans cette démarche
merci véronique morin maire adjointe de
la commune de plaisir des dégâts
l'embellissement de la ville et la
promotion de la nature merci également à
bertrand lyon qui était aussi avec nous
maire de la commune de magny les hameaux
ce week-end le beau temps était au
rendez vous l'occasion justement d'aller
jardiner un peu à guyancourt ils étaient
nombreux aux jardins familiaux le
reportage le reportage à ce sujet de
michael et demi d'euros et de célia gars
tsongo derrière ses grilles ils étaient
une vingtaine de jardiniers amateurs à
profiter du beau temps
ce dimanche 28 février aux jardins
familiaux de guyancourt en cette fin
d'hiver la préparation du terrain est
importante
ce guillon courtois entretient sa part 7
depuis 18 ans ce jour là il est en train
de pêcher la terre fait pour nettoyer le
terrain comme ça à pas et quand patatras
le moment venu on passera gaulle
motoculteurs et puis on pourra cultiver
et à une petite fenêtre là on se dit où
là on va au moins nettoyer on voit au
moins se préparer puisque c'est pas
vraiment la période où on peut tout
planter les jardins familiaux sont
ouverts tous les jours gérard retraité
via environ deux heures trente par jour
il fait tout lui-même on peut appeler ça
du bio a fait vraiment du bureau qu'on
fait là moi je n'ai pas de produits
chimiques
quand il ya des mauvaises herbes hd
arrache moi même nom mais un peu
d'engrais un peu de jeu d'abord j'ai mis
du fumier de cheval
le projet met du terreau je mets mon
frère pour obtenir une parcelle il faut
attendre plusieurs années les 91 sont
déjà toute occupée un terrain vous
coûtera 125 euros à l'année mais si vous
voulez en acquérir un
pas besoin forcément d'avoir la main
verte il n'y a pas d'objectifs de
production auront tant qu'hôtel ce qu'on
demande aux jardiniers c'est
véritablement d'avoir l'envi de mettre
en valeur la parcelle pour pouvoir
planter et récolter le fruit de votre
travail
il faudra attendre encore le printemps
le sport a également profité du beau
temps pour se dé confiné mais très
légèrement au tennis-club de plaisir les
courts extérieurs étaient tous réservé
ce week-end michael et minoru la météo
les a motivé ce dimanche 28 février au
matin ces sportifs amateurs ont ressorti
leurs raquettes pour faire une heure de
tennis entre amis au club de plaisir ses
licenciés ont réservé un court extérieur
sous un soleil quasi printanier dont
j'adore c'est un peu compliqué quand il
pleut au conti neige
donc oui je vais effectivement nous
bretons nous incite à les joindre petit
peu dur moralement ça fait un bien
énorme
ça fait un bien énorme oralement et
c'est vrai que ça nous redonne un peu
d'énergie un peu de de plaisir parce
qu'il n'a pas beaucoup effectivement
souvent dans la société
c'est excellent là ça fait un bien fou
on prend le soleil donc on est on est
très bien on peut pas rêver mieux là
c'est clair ce dimanche matin le tennis
club affiche complet avec des joueurs
sur les cinq courts extérieurs ces
terrains sont les seuls autorisés à la
pratique sportive en ce moment avec la
crise sanitaire
ce taux de remplissage exceptionnel du
week-end est donc rendue possible grâce
aux conditions climatiques de ces
derniers jours
une première depuis de longues semaines
vous savez moi je suis un président
heureux quand je vois les cours qui sont
tous occupés ou quand je vois mes mais
école qui fonctionne à plein rendement
quand quand on fait des compétitions que
ce soit les interclubs jeunes ou adultes
et cetera
c'est la vie d'un club mais cette vie a
complètement pratiquement disparu alors
on essaie de compenser en faisant quand
même de temps j'entends dès que le temps
le permet
des animations à l'extérieur on en fait
de plus en plus au printemps le
tennis-club de plaisir pour accueillir
encore plus de joueurs en extérieur les
différents courts de terre battue seront
bientôt de nouveau praticable
après les gelées de l'hiver le sport
toujours avec l'assemblée générale de la
fédération française de cyclisme
elle était programmée à samedi au siège
de l'instance au vélodrome nationale à
montigny le bretonneux au cours de la
séance le président sortant michel
callot a été réélu largement pour un
nouveau mandat de quatre ans 93,40 2%
des suffrages face à cyrille guimard
ancien coureur et sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france où seul adversaire
pour le scrutin
les caps les quatre prochaines années
s'annoncent charnière avec la
préparation des jo de 2024
une année difficile pour la fédération
en pleine crise sanitaire et avec une
perte de huit mille huit cents licenciés
en 2020 écoutez michel callot au micro
de justin brasil déjà évidemment il va
falloir quand on regarde comment on va
sortir de cette crise et quelles seront
les conséquences pour pour nous pour
notre sport et après ces quatre années
exaltantes et surtout sur le territoire
ici on va aller vers les jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 il y aura tokyo quand même
cette année donc sur le plan sportif
très dense pour nous on a vraiment à
réussir notre transformation économique
et puis presque culturelle de notre
fédération
au regard de la montée en puissance du
vélo dans notre société donc les
chantiers sont vraiment passionnant et
je le qualifierais plutôt comme une
commune olympiade où il faut pas manquer
la fenêtre de tir mais où ça va être
très stimulant et de sport il en sera
question dans quelques minutes sur tv
78e tv 78 y arriver avec votre émission
miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir on savait
le 7-8 sport bien sûr chaque lundi sur
tv 78 quel est le programme
alors le programme c'est ultra simple on
va parler surtout cyclisme à on l'a
entendu juste avant on va parler des
élections à la fédération française de
cyclisme avec la victoire de michel
callot face à cyrille guimard avec plus
de 90% des suffrages en parlera de ça on
parlera également du paris-nice qui
s'élancera ce dimanche depuis les
yvelines depuis à saint cyr à l'école le
lendemain il parle le peloton partira
demain ville sur mon cyan parlera
également golf avec le golf de saint
jean les qui est classé parmi les plus
beaux golfs d'europe et on parlera
également de michu je sais pas ce que ça
vous parle grégory le petit edouard
michu qui est rentré jeunes du psg c'est
ça il est rentré lors de la victoire du
paris saint germain contre dijon 4 buts
à 0 et entre la 88e minute il n'a pas
touché le ballon mais il a joué 7 1 me
blinois il vient du chesnay versailles
un beau programme le sais tu ce sport
c'est dans un instant sur tv 78 merci à
michael c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]